well one endorsement from president
trump 50 cent is now endorsing president
trump urging his fans
on instagram to vote for the president's
reelection because of biden's outrageous
tax plan new polling
by the way by nate silvers 538.com
suggesting that donald trump
has jumped over 10 points with young
african-american voters here with more
former nfl player herschel walker radio
talk show host larry elder
uh larry you've been seeing this and
calling this for some
time and we see it with hispanic
americans now
african-americans moving to trump
doubling
and in some cases tripling numbers he
got in 2016.
does that translate into votes
absolutely it's tough to beat
historically low black unemployment
it's tough to beat choice in public
education when inner city parents black
and brown parents want
but white democrats do not it's awfully
tough to do to beat what donald trump is
doing about illegal immigration
on the grounds that unskilled illegal
take jobs that would otherwise be held
by unskilled black and brown workers
and puts downward pressure on their
wages so for all these reasons black
people
are rethinking their allegiance to the
democratic party and looking at what
trump has done in prison reform
what he's done for historically black
colleges uh this man
has a record that he can run on and in
my opinion he's going to get double if
not triple the amount of support
he got in 2016. herschel if donald trump
praised a former klansman like biden did
if donald trump partnered with a former
ku klux klansman
and fought against integration of
schools because he didn't want his kids
going to schools that he called
racial jungles do you think that the
media might cover that
a little bit or a lot or it would be
non-stop
well i think they'll cover it non-stop
and at the same time i can tell you
right now herschel walker will not be
his friend
but i can tell you that i want everyone
out there to listen to me because i
haven't been offered a
vice president a job for president trump
i haven't been off a cabinet job all
i've been offering is to tell the truth
to the american people
you better get out and vote uh
republican
as lindsey graham was saying right now
if you don't vote republican you're not
going to recognize
america if you let the democrat get in
control your grandkids your kids are not
going to
recognize america because i see what
they're doing they don't tell you the
truth and the truth is
they do not like america the way they're
doing they're going to take your
freedoms away and i'm not going to stand
for it
you know larry look at leo 2.0 you know
where he is today
he's campaigning for donald trump look
what you've done
right you know
and and sean this is why i did this
movie uncle tom because of the
of the grief that leo terrell is getting
right now the grief that ice cube is
getting right now the grief kanye west
is getting
all they're doing is saying maybe just
maybe we ought to rethink our allegiance
to a party that advocates a welfare
state that in my opinion
has incentivized women to marry the
government and incentivizing
men to abandon their financial and moral
responsibilities it is far and away the
number one problem facing
the country in general and black america
in particular and the left is not
talking about this at all
in the 30 seconds left herschel how much
heat have you gotten over supporting
donald trump
well i really haven't gotten any heat
now what i've had to do is educate some
people and i'm most african-american now
is being educated that's why i applaud
50 because he's educated that he know
that that plan that biden had is not
going to work so i'd encourage everyone
else to do the same thing
record low unemployment criminal justice
reform police reform historically black
colleges
thank you both more hannity next